I had inflammation in my lungs they were
pressing up against my ribs and so it
was creating a lot of pain around my
ribcage that was sort of unbearable
about two weeks ago I started to come
down with some mild body aches and
chills those body aches and chills got
worse and worse over the course of about
six days and eventually I started
feeling better then two days later I
came down with severe shortness of
breath and it was pretty quick a sudden
onset I was having trouble even walking
around my apartment I would get winded
just on a trip from my bedroom to the
bathroom and I knew something was really
really wrong and I saw the doctor pretty
quickly and urgent care was fairly empty
as soon as he checked out my symptoms
and saw how difficult it was for me to
talk and speak in full sentences without
gasping for air he told me that I had
the coronavirus I already had sort of
known it by then but he gave me the
confirmation and he gave me the option
to check myself into the ER and I'd be
taken away in an ambulance or go home I
was in a lot of pain at that point I
tried to go to sleep that night but by
about 11:00 p.m. I decided that enough
was enough I think it's also important
to note that I have not been tested for
this virus they're really only testing
severe critical cases I don't want to
take the test away from someone who is
critical and really really needs it
having essentially been given to
presumptive positives from two different
doctors in the New York medical system
I'm fairly confident in the diagnosis
that I've been given so I went back home
and the difficulty breathing has
continued for the last week the real
saving grace has been this pulse
oximeter this is a good way to tell
where you're sort of at in terms of your
oxygen levels and if you would even need
oxygen from the hospital I'll turn this
button on and we'll see what my oxygen
levels are
97 so way better than when I was in the
hospital feel very comfortable you want
to be about a 95 to a 99 the emergency
doctor recommended these lidocaine
patches which I put over both of my rib
cages they typically last through about
12 hours so I rotate them in the morning
and at night and that helps ease some of
the rib pain that I've been having
because of the inflammation I know
there's been a common misconception that
you can't take ibuprofen with this virus
that's absolutely not true you shouldn't
be in pain this is a good pain reliever
these are my go-to s every morning I've
been having tea because the doctor
recommended that I limit my caffeine
intake and I'm normally a coffee addict
so this has been a difficult transition
but I'm more than happy to do it in the
name of getting better I also have some
vitamin C which I'll stir right now that
I have every single morning and of
course handy dandy disinfectant wipes
because I've been wiping down
essentially every surface that I touch
for the last 14 days I'm will continue
to do so as long as I'm symptomatic so
usually I mostly laying down today I'm
feeling well enough to at least be
vertical while I'm eating and I have my
lovely salad here a couple days ago I
probably wouldn't have been able to eat
this actually because my throat was so
swollen but today feels good and gonna
give it a try
even as I talk now I'm struggling to get
through sentences and I'm feeling the
pain in my ribs and have a bit of a sore
throat which is a which is the new
development for me in the last couple of
days I'm hoping this will be my last
symptom since I am on day 14 and I do
feel like I'm on the upswing but I think
the thing that I've learned most from
this entire experience is that mild is a
relative
term I was classified as a mild case or
at least a moderate case because I
wasn't able to get tested and I didn't
require an immediate supply of oxygen
from the hospital but I have to say even
as a milder moderate case this has been
a pretty brutal experience probably one
of the worst bouts of illnesses I've
ever had
you